quoi on ronfle en fait c'est une petite
déformation une on a une luette vous
savez au bout du palais il y a une
petite un petit truc qui s'appelle une
levette en fait cette mouette est trop
grosse elle va gêner l'inspiration et le
l'air qui va ressortir par la bouche
alors il y a des solutions radicales
l'opération chirurgicale plus ou moins
gros suivant les suivants les personnes
c'est un peu comme tout regarder moi par
exemple il a une grosse luette mais hein
et moi une petite
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on a une
grosse couette on se fait opérer
Alouette
non on peut se faire opérer
ou une intervention laser beaucoup plus
légère mais on te fait un gros trou dans
la bouche
enfin si on est